who's been like one of the celebrities
that you saw like singing along your
[__] or posting your [__] that you were
like whoa that's crazy like my song's
that big like they'd reach this person I
ain't gonna lie I probably don't even
remember now because it's just it's so
many so many of them now you you see it
I'd be surprised about all of them for
real cause I ain't know the song was
gonna even I'm like yeah I really like
this song because it correct me from the
cardi B say something about it yeah
everybody business when I say everybody
everybody named mama that's why I'm
shocked so every time it's a new person
I'll just be like that's crazy it's just
going all around I feel like a pound
town remix with cardi B would be
Monumental they were saying that it's a
lot of people that was like it's a lot
of people I want to put on there I don't
know how long what do you want to put on
it I don't know I don't want to name
drop nobody well you know Anna Lee
Choppa did two like officially two
remixes of [__] me outside I know I do
like three or four I might do something
like that
or just put everybody on the same song
you could and just have it you know
Trina would Trina would be dope a lot of
people it's a lot of people I could
think of who are some of the female
rappers you grew up listening to that
you kind of can say you were influenced
by
um I was listening to train uh everybody
used to listen to Nikki everybody used
to sleep
um who else what other females I ain't
gonna I like music so it's nobody
specific like but Trina definitely was
on my training Nikki was definitely on
my uh MP3 player downloaded and my mom
used to heard that she used to be like
you just took us back the MP3 player
yeah that's what I'm saying like when I
used to listen to music and she used to
download [__] like that I used to
download Boosie Webbie all the Boosie
and Webbie music have you met busy yet
yeah I met him
okay because I always tell people when
you meet him he's he doesn't disappoint
what does it mean about it because you
know you'll see sometimes you meet
famous people that you like yeah he cool
and they'll be like oh this guy was a
dick or he's not like how usually you
meet boozy and he's like exactly who you
think he is yeah Boosie cool I mean him
he was like
um when I met him I was with Suki and
she brought me to his house he was
having a little party and him and sukiku
so I was with her and [__] and then he
was like don't never take your glasses
off keep on them [__] glasses
it's a nice I feel like yeah I feel like
the glass is like are dope like I like
the glass yeah I like my little glasses
you need them to see yes I can't see I'm
blind for real damn yes I was mad when I
lost them I lost my glasses before and I
could not see like but I feel like you
could tell I can't see because you could
tell when people need glasses you see it
like I don't think do you need glasses
no my my mom I grew up with my mom and
my grandma were like blind so so you
don't need them no I don't I'm fine
that's why I'm saying like your eyes
wide open I was gonna say you don't look
like you need them okay I don't but I
didn't see people when they are you know
how somebody eyes be squinting yeah and
they look like they trying to see you
can tell like they need them yeah like
that's how my eyes are my eyes be a
little love when I don't got my glasses